[Music]
joining me now on the phone is the radio
voice of the New York Jets since 2002
Bob was shooing here on the rich Isen
show how are you Bob good Rich how are
you I'm doing fine so you if you started
calling Jets games on the
radio uh and they win the division did
you think that's the way it would be
every year
Bob uh yeah it was like you know I'm
sure Dan Marino when he played first
Super Bowl in the second year figured
back every year we just we just happen
to back you are the Marino of radio
sports broadcasters yes for the Jets you
are that yeah you're uh you know and you
remember there was that fateful day in
Foxboro when Mo Lewis basically blew up
the chest of Drew blo and this guy that
nobody had ever heard of named Tom Brady
came trotting on the field and you know
14 years later here we
are so let's talk about the state of the
Jets Bob um at 1 and five fumbling for
the light switch to say the least this
is perhaps the the worst scenario for
them in which to Fumble for the light
switch being in New England on a short
week Tom Brady in this franchise loving
to stick it to him derell revus on the
opposite sideline with the Jets having
very few defensive backs of which to use
to stop all of this from being a boat
race what what do you think the
Jets could do tonight Bob let's let's
start with that their chance in the game
I think is twofold first of all they
have to be able to do what they couldn't
do against dener and that's run the ball
and that may also require Gino to throw
the ball and some early Downs early in
the game to loosen the Patriots up a
little bit but me the Patriots
linebacking core right now is really
banged up we know Gerard Mayo's out for
the year and Dante high toow and Jamie
Collins were both questionable uh this
week with injuries so if you can run the
ball at least that gives your offense a
chance to keep Tom Brady off the field
and get a little bit of confidence for
your quarterback and Dan Connelly was
also questionable for the game tonight
and there have been some rough spots for
the Patriot offensive line I mean if the
Jets have at least as you know there's
one
definable unit y on their team that it
seems like they can count on it's their
pass rush it's their front group they're
second in the league and Sack so you
know if they can get after Tom Brady a
little bit and run the ball then maybe
they have a
chance it's remarkable Bob because in
the years that they were going to the
AFC Championship game uh it was the
scheme and the back end of the defense
that was the backbone of the Rex Ryan uh
coordination and now they've got that
pass rush that they could get from their
front four and it's the other seven
that's been somewhat of a question mark
certainly the back four with uh Dimitri
Patterson being the best that the
general manager gave uh Rex Ryan and he
didn't even make the season so my
question I have for you is how is Rex
dealing with all of this he's having a
tough time I mean he's doing what he can
you know he's gone with two polar
opposite game plans the last two weeks
two weeks ago he basically said I'm not
going to have Philip Rivers just bleed
me to death we're going to get after him
and they zero blitzed or had to be a
dozen times in that game and Philip
Rivers basically if you know anybody saw
that game he was just throwing julum
balls just 50/50 balls and basically
saying you know what I'm just going to
throw this thing to a spot and my guy's
better than your guy and all day long
they were and so last week Rex flipped
it and he showed pton Manning every
possible coverage look that he could and
he only rushed three and four basically
the whole game I don't know if there
were five snaps in the game where the
Jets rushed more than four they played
coverage all day and they tried to
shorten the game and they almost got it
done um but I mean he's he's he's
playing with what he has to play with
you mentioned Demitri Patterson he went
awall um they drafted a kid Dexter
McDougall in the third round he went on
IR in training camp and Dean Miller who
was the number nine pick in the draft
last year and just cannot stay healthy
and now he's on IR with an Achilles so
those were supposed to be their top
three corners coming into the season and
none of them played more than six
games what do you think they should do
at quarterback
Bob well I mean I think they should play
Gino Smith the rest of the season at the
very least and then see where they're at
I've maintained that all along um at
this point and I never really saw a
scenario where playing Michael Vick was
smart uh you know it's about learning
what you've got they drafted him in the
second round they didn't draft him in
the first round they didn't draft him a
fifth overall let they did Mark Sanchez
they drafted him in the second round so
if it turns out after two years that
Gino Smith's not the guy it's not like
you turned your franchise over to him
for five years the way you would if he
was a top 10 pick um so I think you plan
the rest of the year and you see what
you have at this point you know they're
one and five you're gonna put Michael
Vick in there you know and what and
expect what I guess so to me if you're
thinking in any way long-term planning
at the most important position on your
field you play G the rest of the
year okay and I'm going to ask you this
question Bob because you must yeah I'm
thinking you you may know because you're
around the team you hear people talking
you hear the media talking nobody knows
what movie Gino Smith went to see do you
know which movie Gino Smith went to see
in San
Diego I am also in the dark on
that deep
information I promise rich though if I
find out you'll be my first call and
we'll meet in a dark parking garage
somewhere and I will fill you
in this this week could be it could be
if I stay last week it was gone guy as I
saw on The Daily News back page but
that's that's that's information that
this show considers gold Bob what movie
did he see so if you hear please I mean
you you host a national show to me
there's a perfect example the difference
between New York and every place else
you know the the bills bench EJ Emanuel
he's their firstr pick they mention and
it's barely a ripple in NFL news circles
she meeting back page of the
paper you know it's the world it's a
city that never sleeps you know it's New
York you know it's Rex right it's the
place where TBO Mania reached a fever
pitch and we all saw what he did in
Denver TBO oh come it's a different
world Bob right there there's nothing
like three carries for two yards into
the heart of the line to uh to create T
Mania that I was the people at least
that I
enjoyed Bob thanks so much I appreciate
you joining the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at no Eastern on
audience